llegó el momento de la revista de prensa
para ello ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez en más de euros a bienvenida
muy buen día feliz jueves ya casi
acabando la semana vamos a comenzar
entonces con las últimas novedades del
caso de la tenista de élite china peng
shuai la preocupación acerca de su
supuesta desaparición vamos a hacer
entonces un repaso de la prensa
internacional rosa buenos días raúl
exacto hemos hecho una selección de
distintos periódicos de distintas partes
del mundo pero este tema realmente está
llenando titulares de cientos de
periódicos es un tema que ya se ha
venido hablando en los últimos días pero
que ha explotado después de la noticia
que comentaremos acto seguido pero vamos
a empezar con un artículo de página 12
de este medio argentino que hace un
resumen del caso para ubicarnos
recordemos esta tenista peng shuai hizo
una publicación en weibo en la
plataforma social china parecida a
twitter en que denunciaba que el alto
funcionario chino y ex vice
yx perdón ex y ser ministro exacto
la habría violado yanga o lid entonces
esta publicación fue eliminada al cabo
de media hora de la red social y
posteriormente se bloquearon
prácticamente todas las búsquedas en el
internet chino en referencia a este caso
bien hubo silencio por parte de las
autoridades chinas mientras que dentro
de la mundo del tenis mo internacional
empezaron a alzar las voces grandes
deportistas como djokovic o como naomi
osaka así como la asociación femenina de
tenis no perdiendo un poco de
explicaciones y aclaraciones sobre el
paradero desconocido de la tenista peng
shuai bien hasta ayer no se supo nada
más lo que surgió ayer fue que la
televisión estatal las chinas cgt n
publicó un email que la tenista habría
mandado supuestamente a la asociación
femenina de tenis veamos este email este
comunicado que se hizo público a través
de twitter a ver si nuestros compañeros
nos lo pueden mostrar aquí bien este
sería el email que lo traducimos
rápidamente en que supuestamente la
tenista hola a todos soy peng shuai las
noticias publicadas por la w tea no han
sido confirmadas por mí las noticias
incluyendo las acusaciones de agresiones
sexuales son falsas no estoy
desaparecida ni en peligro sólo he
estado descansando en mi casa bien
fijémonos en un detalle raúl en el que
han puesto el foco los internautas y es
en este curso que vemos en la segunda
línea que no se sabe muy bien de dónde
salen ya el presidente de la w tea de la
asociación familia de tenis ha expresado
públicamente sus dudas sobre la
veracidad de este email que le ha
llegado pero qué duda mucho que haya
sido redactado y escrito por la tenista
y en este sentido es en el que publica
el resto de la prensa internacional
volvamos si les parece al primer gráfico
que veíamos de hecho al yazira dice la
doblete a cuestiona el email
supuestamente enviado por la tenista
china peng shuai
steve simon el presidente de la w tea
dice que su preocupación sólo ha
aumentado después de recibir este email
lo monte este medio francés dice un
email atribuido a peng shuai la campeona
de tenis china aumenta las inquietudes
la bbc- también comenta pensó hay dudas
sobre el correo electo pensó hay dos
puntos dudas sobre el correo electrónico
de la estrella del tenis chino y el 'new
york times' el tenis femenino desafía la
narrativa de china respecto a la tenista
desaparecida bueno y ojalá pronto
podamos verla y que esté en buen estado
de salud y también anímico rosa vamos
ahora con el país dice los titubeos de
bailén en la política y en la política
migratoria marcan su reunión con lópez
obrador en una reunión que va a tener
lugar esta tarde exacto este artículo es
un poco la antesala lo que se puede
esperar de esta reunión trilateral que
se reanuda después de haber sido pausada
después de que no se celebrará durante
la administración trump nos recordemos
se van a reunir el presidente mexicano
lópez obrador el presidente
estadounidense joe biden y el primer
ministro canadiense ella es quien
trudeau y a pesar de que son múltiples
los temas que figuran en la agenda como
el cambio climático y la escasez de
suministros a nivel mundial o la
recuperación post pandemia evidentemente
el foco va a estar en la cuestión
migratoria de hecho vemos como la imagen
que ilustra este artículo es esta imagen
que cada vez que nos referimos a ella
raúl yo me quedo sin palabras
de bueno en la frontera de texas y
méxico y de hecho concluye este artículo
un punto que ha cambiado respecto a las
peticiones de mexico para amd en dar
contrapartidas en el tema migratorio y
es como contraprestación a las cesiones
en materia migratoria méxico quiere que
estados unidos colabore con neutralizar
el tráfico de armas de su país al sur y
que terminan en manos del narcotráfico
hasta ahora la casa blanca se ha
mostrado inflexible vamos ahora con the
gardian los menonitas de live y columbia
qué pasa con esto finitas de rosa bien
pues éste es una foto o reportaje que
les animamos a que entren en la página y
lo vean porque las imágenes son
realmente preciosas que muestra como
desde 2016 menonitas sobre todo
provenientes de méxico que estaban
instalados en mexico es hasta entonces
llegaron colombia a raíz de los acuerdos
de paz y esta es una muestra sobre el
día a día en esta zona del este de
colombia entre pues digamos entre bogotá
y la frontera con venezuela y estas son
un poco las fotos del día a día de este
pueblo también puede ser en una zona
donde hay una convivencia bien curiosa
entre colombianos también muchos
inmigrantes venezolanos y este pueblo
originario de europa bueno rosa
muchísimas gracias entonces por esta
información de revista de prensa nos
vemos mañana con más ahora vamos a darle
paso a nuestra primera invitada del día
[Música]